في مختبر صيدليه درفتش في باريس تحضر
الادويه في هذه الحلقه انه المضاد الحيوي
الشائع اموكسيسيلين منذ توقف الناس عن
ارتداء الكمامات في فتره ما بعد جائع
كورونا بداوا يصابون بمزيد من العدوى مره
اخرى فزاد الطلب على الادويه ولم يعد
باستطاعه شركات الادويه الكبرى مواكبه
الطلب
على مدار العامين الماضيين لذا لم يعد
الناس محصنين بطريقه طبيعيه من حيث كيفيه
تفاعلهم مع الامراض لقد حضينا بالحمايه
الزائده هذا هو اول شتاء تتم فيه ازاله
الكيمامات لذلك فالناس اكثر حساسيه
للامراض الصيدليه في المستوصف شهيدنا
زياده من نحو 30 الى 40% في عدد الوصفات
الطبيه للمضادات الحيويه او المسكنات مثل
البراسيتامول
تنتج 40 صيدليه في جميع انحاء فرنسا
كبسولات اموكسيسيلين للاطفال منذ اسبوعين
حيث تواجه البلاد نقصا في ادويه الاطفال
الصيدليات الاخرى بدات هذه الصيدليه في
باريس ايضا انتاجها بناء على طلب الوكاله
الفرنسيه لسلامه المنتجات الصحيه كل يوم
بعد العمل ينتجون كبسولات تذهب الى اكثر
من 500 الف صيدليه في جميع انحاء فرنسا
انهم مقلق للغايه حيث تشهد البلاد
وارتفاعا في الحمى القرمزيه والتهابات
اللوزتين الخطيره التي قتلت بالفعل تسعه
اطفال ويحذر المختصون في مجال الصحه ايضا
من نقص المحتمل في دول اوروبيه اخرى مثل
ايطاليا وكذلك في كندا والولايات المتحده